joining me now is emmy award-winning
actor
bradley whitford best known for his role
as josh lyman
in the west wing or as i shorthand it
basically the reason why everyone who
i've ever met on a
political campaign is there everybody is
there because they want to be
josh lyman i'm so happy to chat with you
today how are you feeling
after today's historic events
uh i thought the the entire
event uh was gorgeous i i cried
multiple times i started crying
when the pledge of allegiance was
signed i thought it was beautiful and i
want us to enjoy this
uh the enormity of
the task uh at hand
the not the you know we talk about the
big lie
of uh saying a
legitimate certified election uh uh
you know wasn't legitimate there are
so many big lies uh that have been
coming
frankly from the republican party for so
long
whether the lie about climate change the
lie that they care about
election integrity when in fact they
would not exist
without voter suppression aimed at
communities of color
they're so brazen about it they're
they're looking to
up end the the elections
in in other states where they just
happen to be where where the black
communities
showed up so i'm thinking uh of
of how what that task is going forward
and i think biden is aware i think we
all get scared
when he says you know i can work with
these people
uh and i think we need to be skeptical
uh
we can work with them but we have to
acknowledge
uh the fact that you know our leg is
broken
before we can heal it and in terms of
the way we deal with race in this
country
uh our you know our leg is busted
uh and i don't wanna if we sweep that
under under the rug again
i mean i'm from wisconsin what the
republican party has done in wisconsin
think of what they've done they they
they try to sabotage the usps
they do everything they can to make it
difficult for people to vote
they do last-minute lawsuits in
wisconsin
they passed a law so that you could not
count the mail-in votes
because they want to have that thing
they can be suspicious of
later on uh the county clerk and where i
was born in
in dane county they found out he was
unwrapping the ballots so they he wasn't
going to count them but
was just going to load them into the
machine on election day they passed a
law against that
and so we
we really need to deal with that i do
hope that
election
rights and security are a part of the
biden agenda
up front i really do
absolutely i think that you know
ensuring that everyone has access you
know trying to remove those
voter suppression uh tactics and the the
voter id laws that republicans like to
put into place
um to suppress the vote you know opening
it up for everyone is the best case
scenario
and whoever wins wins that's how this
should work in terms of um
your character on the west wing i joked
in the lead-in that essentially every
person i've ever met on a campaign is
there because they wanted to be
josh lyman and i think the west wing in
a lot of ways
is the idealistic democratic
administration
in a hypothetical world where
republicans are similar to the way they
are in real life
um but certainly both sides are uh
represented in a very particular way
in terms of how you know a moral uh
man like president josiah bartlett would
handle this moment i think there are
some similarities uh with
with him and joe biden in the sense that
they're both led by their faith and
they're deeply moral men
speak to um how important it is
in this moment of the pandemic of the
the racial reckoning that we need in
this country
um you know people who can confront
those big lies
talk a bit about why joe biden in your
view is the right man
for this kind of moment where you need
somebody with a working moral compass
well listen i i you may disagree but
it was very interesting to me as
somebody who's active in democratic
politics i'm just noticing my fuzzy
background
i i don't know why that's happening uh
um but it was very it was striking
to me that a party that i am always
worried about
uh uh fracturing and
uh losing power um that
we have when when we're united i have
never felt
the party so united
from uh aoc to john kasich
uh uh there there became this
understanding
that this is exactly who
we need at this moment we need
uh honesty we need competence uh
we need someone who has suffered
um and who has been strengthened
uh uh by it um
so there's there's a a lot in common
uh with chad bartlett you know it always
drives me crazy too just as a democratic
activist
that horrible word brand the word
brand part of the reason
that uh we have one of the reasons we
have the kind of minority rule
and tyranny uh of the of the the
minority rule now
is that their brand somehow in
the most orwellian way
they're they have uh god
they have the flag somehow they
they have uh we're good with money i
mean
none of these things are true in terms
of biden's
faith which is sincere as bartlett's
was sincere as martin sheen's faith is
sincere
i am glad you know that
uh the voices the religious voices
we hear in this country tend to be
voices of condemnation
and exclusion and i see a lot of people
going around
talking about their faith in jesus as if
jesus
was a you know supply-side guy
walking uh uh walking by uh
lepers saying don't help them you're
gonna make them lazy it's completely
crazy so i'm
grateful to have someone whose uh
interpretation of of
christianity jives
uh with reality and with and with my
interpretation as well
we just have one more minute but i want
to ask about the fact that we're still
in the middle of a pandemic what are
your hopes for
you know how quickly the biden
administration uh
could it can implement their plans to uh
try to solve this pandemic as quickly as
possible because
you know performers like yourself actors
like yourself artists like yourself
you know you make art and you need to be
able to do what you do so
hopefully we'll be able to do that do
you feel optimistic biden will be able
to tackle this
issue uh and get us out of the crisis
i feel very uh confident in ron clayne
i feel very confident in um
andy slavitt who i know is going to be
part of
the vaccine distribution effort
um you know
it is just extraordinary that
so many innocent uh people have lost
their lives in the most tragic way
and we've had an administration that had
no interest
in in uh dealing
with the virus in the first place tried
to avoid it saw it as a publicity
problem
and made no effort to
do vaccine distribution i i
am uh optimistic uh
that uh competence is gonna feel
uh a lot different and i i think it's
coming fast
absolutely i mean i this morning i said
today was the first day
we had a president during the pandemic
uh because up until this point we really
didn't have one bradley whitford
thank you so much for joining us and
please stay safe um it's been great to
watch all of your activism
around turning out the vote in november
it's so great to see people get involved
in their democracy
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories thanks for watching